a Major League umpires being called a
hero for his life-saving actions off the
field cell phone video captured the
dramatic scene yesterday on a Pittsburg
bridge when a woman standing on the edge
was threatening to jump 34 year-old John
Tom Payne was just happened to be
walking by when he realized what was
happening and he rushed in to help
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn shows us the tense moments we had
the plate umpire John to pain making the
biggest save of all before the game or
what a story that is it's not exactly
how veteran umpire John Tim Payne
imagined his day would begin during an
afternoon jog over the Roberto Clemente
bridge something caught some Payne's eye
he sees a woman climb over the railing
and looked toward the Allegheny River at
that time just kind of hooked her arm
with mine so you don't do that it's just
as good over here I said why don't you
just go grab some lunch and talk about
whatever I'm better off on this side
just let me go this cell phone video
shows the woman on the wrong side of the
bridge ready to jump I said no we're
here to help yeah I said she's like
you'll forgive me tomorrow so I'll never
forget you you can have my promise on
that with the help of other bystanders
and eventually emergency responders Tim
Payne lifted the woman to safety to
couple of times you know slip their legs
off the ledge and became dead weight and
I just think I'm Catholic you know this
has got to be a good ending and not a
bad ending this picture
captured by a local photographer shows
Tim Payne comforting the unidentified
woman just expresses that importance of
being a good person on and off the field
just hope that you know a lady at this
safe now and she's in a better spot he's
a good guy
nice job tonight twice I guess the 34
year old campaign makes a living
diffusing difficult situations on the
field nearly every single day but says
this was just pure instinct this isn't
about me I appreciate this opportunity
but I know this is just for her and that
people care about her and just quite a
bit it's a positive story Don Payne says
he called his wife after the woman was
taken away telling her he helps save
someone's life and his arms were still
shaking he called the Pirates Ray's game
only hours after this happened and he'd
look up at the bridge and he think to
himself I saved somebody's life I
imagine it was scary for him too but
what a good man instincts and all the
stories you hear about sports that
aren't so attractive free attract one
for Major League Baseball this is pretty
impressive we hit flat thanks so much